leavened uzum choose ensemble are
performing an historical comedy tonight
it's about an ottoman sultan who tries
to censor a theater groups performances
similarities to present day Turkey are
intentional the audience knows that the
actors are walking a thin line for the
city authorities in Istanbul 11 uzum
true is a public enemy in late August he
lost the job that he'd held for 25 years
because he made a public speech and
wrote on the internet criticizing the
AKP government he's pessimistic about
freedom of expression in his cultural
sector theatro beaded even good Okla the
people in charge of Istanbul
state-sponsored theater are slaves to
authority they decide in the repertoire
even though they know nothing about
theatre I've always expressed my opinion
freely a well-known actor you love I'm
meeting everyone knows I won't keep my
mouth shut get out of between units of
night liga de almas load on let's meet
you now he can perform only with private
theatre groups he knows he's relatively
fortunate other people who criticize the
government ended up in jail or were
subjected to violence King shoe on the
cute little dog the place shows what
it's like in today's Turkey most
theaters have no freedom anymore cabaret
artist and satirist in particular are
being stripped of their creative freedom
the state does everything it can to
impede their work we're here to show
solidarity if I didn't [ __ ] yo holla
bengali neo
a general election is scheduled for
November but there's little evidence of
any campaigning the government's
zero-tolerance policy toward its critics
and the recent terror attacks have
deepened the rift between President
Reggie uptight barons opponents and his
supporters they refuse to listen to
criticism of their leader I give any
update or whatever the AKP does it's
right it needs to regain its absolute
majority top you had accused in how she
didn't young the shuttle everyone makes
mistakes including the government the
government's critics should take a look
in the mirror and ask themselves if
they're always right our government
should be treated with respect Sonny
Coloma kwasind we head to the city of
Edina on the Bulgarian border a
traditional secular stronghold student
kadir yavuz and his friends are getting
ready for another anti-government
protest even though he's still haunted
by what happened at the rally for peace
and democracy in Ankara on october the
10th he was just a few meters away from
our two bombs exploded killing over 100
people you do can you he's all success
number body parts everywhere we had to
climb over them all news in the NOC we
were in shock holy SH Oakland atageini
we didn't understand what happens on
losing the court creative indirectly the
people responsible for this bloodbath
are the same people who instigate fear
and make out the country would be
plunged into chaos if it weren't for
them the 22 year old has to be careful
what he says he was given and 11 months
suspended sentence for insulting the
president his case made headlines across
the country he appeared before the judge
in handcuffs for calling hair dhawan a
thief and a murderer van condemn soul
mummy stelio Salma McKissack I wanted to
defend myself before the judge seen its
ride spoken only two sentences when he
cut me off he said it was enough
oh that he had already decided how to
sentence me I'm shaky the a-league if I
had no idea the legal system in this
country had gone downhill this badly she
shoots you ahead ya basha and his
friends run a left-wing cultural center
in adurnam they say they can't even
speak openly at university anymore would
you live in the US does all the
professors are under pressure by the
government they pass on that pressure to
us we're increasingly restricted in what
we can say you can lose if I dated Lee
James alumni here that's meola spiraling
violence growing repression young
Democratic thinkers like Qatar yash are
swimming against the tide even though
they could end up paying a high price
bikini Istanbul theatre the Sultan has
been outwitted and the ensemble
performed the play Lebanon ism sure has
appealed against his dismissal and is
willing to take his case to the Supreme
Court if he has to the Ankara bombings
have made him even more determined to
fight for the future of his country
shimmy daily this which we are not I'll
Todd would once again they blame the
people who criticize the government and
the state is not to play finish give me
this damn it I can't go on like this the
government just sits back and says it
did what it could to protect the
demonstrators but it didn't a little
Buddha shared a deep get you take me to
them that Democratic thinkers like
leaven uzum chu are preparing for the
long haul the curtain will not be
falling on the akp anytime soon